oh my god it's been over three days
since i shot spider-man news into my
veins going through withdrawals
give me some leaks all right so we're
gonna watch today from cosmic wonder
spider-man 3 toby mcguire update and
leaked footage
breakdown what say what guys subscribe
to cosmic wonder if you haven't done so
already
tyrone magnus has the hodge twins we got
cosmic
how's it going everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder and as
we get closer to the
end of this year 2020 where we had
absolutely no
new marvel content either shows or
movies
fans are really looking forward to the
spider-man 3 teaser that we were
promised for those of you who may not be
aware
a sony executive promised a couple of
months ago that we would be getting our
first look at spider-man 3 in december
that's
it right there
so we can assume that we are still going
to get our first look and an official
account for paramount pictures
recently posted on twitter that so many
pictures is going to give
fans a gift for christmas a box that if
you open it
all three spider-man from the 21st
century tom holland toby mcguire and
andrew garfield will appear in the same
film and according to them it's coming
on december 25th
and as i promised i'll keep everybody
updated if i hear anything about it
which leads us to today's video we have
some more information about toby
county in spider-man 3 and there's a
teaser trailer going around that is
supposedly leaked that we're going to
talk about what
what teaser trailer
no it's not this giveaway is a modak
from the avengers game funko pop
provided by heroes hideout.com
now of course as we all know spider-man
3 is going to be a spider-verse film
to the extent of what exactly it's going
to be we're not too sure
not sure if these characters are going
to be a cameo or if they're going to
have a major role in the film
but in reality it kind of doesn't matter
because fans just want to see tom
holland toby mcguire and angel
that's the peter i want pretty much 99
confirmed according to a new report from
daniel richmond
toby mcguire is just about to sign and
sony doesn't want to show anything
until he does sign his official tweet
said i hear they want to close things
with toby before showing us anything
they need that money shot this means
that for the teaser they actually want
to show us
all three spider-man and confirmed that
it is in fact a spider-verse movie which
would be a great move by them because
it's just tough mugger signing the
contract
from marvel and the whole entire
internet would freak out if on december
25th
they showed us a picture of all three
spider-man together and revealed the
effect
now keep in mind that toby maguire has
already committed to spider-man 3 you
don't begin this movie and plan a big
spider-verse movie without getting a
commitment
they're most likely just working on
final details as far as money is
concerned which is usually the case but
again toby is most likely already
committed because you don't plan a
really big movie like this unless you've
already got all the commitments
so hopefully the teaser on december 25th
if it does indeed come on christmas day
will confirm the spider verse and
speaking of teaser there is supposedly a
leaked
spider-man 3 teaser all right what the
hell are we talking about here
a ton of questions about i'll show it
right now so you know what i'm talking
about and then
break it down
now i wish i could tell you that this is
real and it's a teaser from spider-man 3
but i doubt it i've been told that it's
from a spider-man
fan film although i haven't been able to
find the film yet but regardless i don't
think it's real because i don't think
music would be done for this scene yet
and that is just spider-man
in the ring probably from a battle of
some sort
it's not really much of a teaser but it
still most likely isn't from spider-man
3.
this isn't something that would really
get fans super excited about the movie
boy wants to show everybody aka
the money shot as they will show you the
whole music that's what we want as well
because everybody will lose their minds
so sadly but not so sadly i don't think
this is real but hopefully we get a
real teaser in just a few days i don't
think it could be here
it can't be footage spider-man 3
so let me know your predictions in the
comments down below don't forget to like
the video
i got thoughts hodge i mean cosmic
i got thoughts oh man i got thoughts all
right john let's put out those thoughts
thank you for the information here
okay so december 25th is when they're
supposed to release something i need to
give you guys a heads up if there is
indeed a teaser trailer
john and i are supposed to be spending
christmas with our loved ones that day
fortunately love loved ones does not
encompass us yeah we don't really
you know we don't need to be in the same
room that day
every day is christmas except for
christmas for us
so you know it's spider-man we have to
honor our loving agreements okay we
can't be like those christmas movies
who are like oh do i decide between work
or spending time with my family
i always choose work john chose his
family dick i'm sorry i always
choose i'm doing it that's the american
way so what i'm saying is is that
all this talking just to get to this
point i'll probably do a teaser trailer
alone
and then john will take time to go to
his room
with his family to do his separately and
then we'll just upload them like an hour
apart or something like that
if there is a teaser trailer i'm
thinking though it's probably not going
to be a trailer
they said a teaser now a teaser could be
anything it could be the official title
reveal
it could be just a photo of the three of
them together
that's all it could really be they have
started filming this and if if it's true
that they don't want to release a
trailer
until they're all together and if toby
maguire which i believe he's already
signed and then these
reports are just coming out if that's
true if he hasn't
already done the final steps and
negotiations and began to be
uh you know in filming with the crew and
such and i don't know how you get a
trailer out
yeah exactly unless they did something
preemptively
and then decided to cut like another
deal around the movie which would be
incredibly risky to do
i don't know i mean it could be
something where you have maybe all three
of them together doing some kind of
thing where they just talk to the camera
hype us up and sure and you know do it
that way because yeah i don't know
really
other than the footage they have with
tom holland what they could do
because they would have already had to
have them on set and to have them on set
they would have to have signed him for
something i don't really
know what to expect unless again i i
have to imagine that a lot of the kinds
of news and leaks that we get are
on that delay so maybe they have had
time
in these last couple of weeks here to
put something together who knows you
know i wouldn't mind if they
they haven't done something like this
for a movie in a long time
it's really rare when they do something
like this where imagine like a 90s trey
who like the
batman or robin once heard
in a video exactly they could do
something as simple as that
even without uh having tommy mcguire
signed on and
supposedly supposedly the rumor goes
that you're not even supposed to see
them till the third act of the film
with what they've shot so far they have
probably enough to make a teaser trailer
at least with tom holland yeah at least
to at least with the main guy
at least with this guy no one has been
paying attention to
this entire time uh because yeah i mean
you could easily
like a one-minute teaser yeah give us at
least a taste for what the movie will be
like and have the poor tense of the
multiverse in
that yeah you know maybe they shot
scenes with doctor strange already you
know
so like actually to lead with your big
teaser like even with captain america
civil war i don't think we got
spider-man in the trailer until the
second one so if you
start off with the spider-verse
like the other spider-man i don't know i
kind of feel like that's a little too
much for your first trailer i think
first trailer keep it grounded for what
you can
do and then your second trailer
then you could show the other spiderman
well and what i wonder too is
it's entirely possible that they might
show us some new footage of tom and then
just splice in
old footage of the other ones just to
confirm it could just be some type of
edited promo trailer but if they don't
want if they i'm
what i'm saying is that they don't need
the footage of the other people and in
fact it'd be better
in my opinion if you don't we'll see
guys we'll see maybe it's just a box set
of the films
all together and that leaked footage
[ __ ] is totally
[ __ ] subscribe to cause wonder if you
haven't done so already subscribe to us
we cover spiderman news whenever we
we feel like yeah i want to hear about
that
hit that like button we'll catch you
guys soon
you